in the past 3 months has gotten over
51,000
clicks just from In the past 90 days,
this website has gotten over 81,000
total clicks and 11 million impressions.
But as you can see, this is specifically
for web. So this is when people search
up on Google and they click our URLs and
go over to our website. That is
considered a click. But there's actually
other ways in which you can get traffic.
Most SEO guys focus on web clicks, but
you can actually get clicks from other
places like images, video, and news. If
we go over to images, we can see that
this website in the past 3 months has
gotten over 51,000
clicks just from images. So that's
51,000 new potential visitors going over
to your website just from images that
you've posted. In the past 28 days,
we've gotten over 14,000 clicks and 4.7
million impressions just from images.
So if we go down to our queries, we'll
be able to see what queries are bringing
in clicks from images. So you can see
that this is different medical
conditions. If you go over to those blog
posts, we can actually see the images um
embedded into those blog posts. So the
way that this works is someone goes on
Google and because it's image first
query and Google tries its best to show
the best um possible search result for
that user. So if they include pictures
or images within their search query, of
course they're going to show them
pictures and images. And as you can see
here, our client's website is ranked
number one and number two for these
images. So people are naturally going to
click on that um image. And then what
they're going to do is they're going to
want to read more. So they're naturally
going to click over to your website. So
this is an easy easy way for you to get
more clicks over to your website. So if
you If you back over to our Google
Search Console, we'll be able to see the
queries again and the pages. So, if you
go ahead and take a look at any of these
pages, the crazy part is is that we did
not intentionally try to get image
clicks. We naturally got image clicks
because we created high-quality content
and we created high-quality images. So,
if you take a look at these images,
these are really, really good,
high-quality images that you can
actually create automatically. You don't
have to manually create these images. We
use my tool, Word Rocket,
and we generated the articles with the
custom images throughout the articles.
And because the images were so in-depth
and they were useful to the actual
article itself, those images were then
picked up by Google. So, if you wanted
to generate images automatically within
your article to help you get more clicks
on images, you can use Word Rocket for
yourself if you haven't tried it out
before. I've actually went ahead and
created a skill that audits your website
and find opportunities for image clicks
or video clicks. If you want to get this
uh complete skill, comment images below
and I'll send it over to you.
So, I hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video. As you can see, there's other
ways in which you can get you can get
clicks over to your website other than
directly from the web. Take care and
I'll see you in the next one.